we've seen how to create service level
objectives for services running on gke
but what if your services aren't today
i'm going to show you how to create
custom services and define slos to
measure their reliability
this is the stackdoctor
[Music]
as we covered in our earlier episode
services running on gke are
automatically discovered by slo
monitoring
if you're using the seo service mesh if
you're not you can easily select gk
entities and create services against
them
if your services aren't on gke you need
to define them as custom services
as you can see you're not limited to
just the out of the box service types in
service monitoring
you can create custom services you have
two options you can use the api directly
or you can use an automation tool like
terraform once the service is created
you can then use the ui to create slos
against it
let's take a look at the api method
first to invoke the api make a post
request to the services endpoint within
your project specifying the service id
as a parameter
the body of the request should contain
the name you'd like to see in the ui
and there you are now that the service
has been created you can use the ui to
create an slo against it
note that you have to specify other as
the metric for your sli
this is a custom service and there's no
automatic measure of performance or
availability for it
as such you need to have a good sli for
the service for a start you might be
able to use a metric emitted by the
google cloud load balancer such as
request count
otherwise you'll need to instrument your
service to emit slis
for an example take a look at our
earlier episode by using open telemetry
to do just that
as you can see creating a custom service
using an api call is pretty
straightforward
from there you could use the api or the
ui to define your slo
but what if you want to automate this
process this is where terraform comes in
you may remember that we covered using
terraform to create monitoring
configurations like uptime checks
dashboards and learning policies in the
previous episode
if not no worries we'll link to that
episode below to quickly bring you up to
speed
terraform is an open source tool that
allows us to define infrastructure and
monitoring configurations as code
that includes defining services and slos
here's how you can define a service and
an slow against it in terraform
let's walk through the code together so
that it's clear
first define the basics specify google
cloud as the provider and define your
service
for the service you just need to provide
a service id that's unique to your
project and a display name
next define the slo specify an id for it
and the display name
next specify whether you want to use a
request base or a windows based sli
then specify the metric you want to use
as your sli
and finally determine how you'd like the
sli to be evaluated
note that i'm just using a single metric
in this example for a request based slo
you might
have separate metrics that you want to
use to represent total requests and good
requests or
perhaps the same metric with different
filters applied both of those are
absolutely supported by slo monitoring
to allow you to calculate a ratio
the final step is to define your target
or goal expressed as a fraction that
should be less than one
and your compliance period as either a
rolling or calendar window
once your definition is done run the
terraform plan command
to validate your configuration and make
sure that two resources will be created
your service and your slo finally
run terraform apply to actually create
the resources
confirm that you want to do this at the
prompt and verify that the two resources
you wanted
got created return to the console
and verify that your service was created
and that it has an slo defined against
it
in the services details screen make sure
that your service is currently compliant
with your slo
if that's what you expect thanks for
joining me today
we'll learn how to define custom
services using the api and terraform
and how to automate setting slos against
our services now you are ready to start
defining your own services and setting
lasso lows against them
thanks for watching and come back soon
for more this is the stack doctor
stay healthy out there
you